good morning happy wednesday i'm back in
vegas i've been away for a full month
i've been in california living uh at my
mom's house thank you mom for the entire
month of august because i just figured
it would be
the
the most mutually beneficial for
everyone
that's what they're hearing in the
background
my duty
um if i just went out there because one
most of my team members are out in
california two
taika's cousins that are
a month apart older than him um are also
out there they live with all my or my
brother my mom they all live on the same
property so
all my family's all together so taika
could be out there i can get some work
done i could spend time with my family
so he didn't have to go to school it
just made so much sense to just hang out
there for the month um and as you guys
know we are selling our house it went up
in value
significantly from the year that we
moved into this year if you don't know
what i'm talking about check out the
video um that we've already uploaded
kind of catching you up on all of that
but yes we are moving again
so um we're gonna start packing by we i
mean me i'm gonna start packing but
because we've been moving so much i feel
like i'm such a moving expert that i
already know
um what the steps are we didn't get to
even fully move into this place because
as you guys know we had interior design
plans set out from the beginning we
added
like this thing we installed it we
installed marble
we were gonna paint the whole place like
it was just gonna look [ __ ] sick but
you know life takes us in different
directions and this direction that it
took us in was way more lucrative than
spending
a ton
for something
um
that can change so
when we saw the opportunity
present itself we grabbed it by the nuts
you know i'm sorry
grab your book or nuts anyway i do want
to give you guys
um
a little pointer that i did when i was
out in california
um
i started buying a lot of the shipping
supplies from this company called uline
and if you haven't heard of uline you
have to
order from mulan especially if you're a
small business because they do a lot of
like bulk orders they ship really fast
and they really cater just to businesses
so um a lot of the prices are super
competitive so what i ended up doing was
i bought all the shipping supplies and
had them
shipped or all the moving supplies and
had them shipped to
my house before i even got here
yesterday so i think they were here like
two or three days ago um so now i can
start assembling boxes packing
everything start moving stuff i am gonna
start selling a bunch of stuff like i'm
gonna put that for sale because we don't
need it oh and
because you probably haven't watched
if you haven't watched the video um
our other house is currently getting
built and it's not going to be finished
until late september early october
um but the new buyers want to move in
by mid-august
so there's a few months where we're
going to be renting a a small little
apartment
it's fine
it's going to be worth it so we're going
to move two more times
but the cool thing about the for the
move from here to the apartment is that
it's going to be fully furnished we're
only going to be living there for maybe
like two and a half months maybe if all
goes well and there's no more delays in
our building our house building process
um so all of our current furniture um
will be just sitting in storage waiting
for us so that's kind of the rad part
that i don't have to move everything
from one place to another place to
another place another place it just goes
into a pod and boom
we just [ __ ] move yeah so this is
going to be one of the things that i'm
going to get rid of or sell
those chairs i'm going to get rid of
because we've had them for far too long
and they're pretty cheap like a lot of
these items like that i want to sell
that i'm going to
keep i don't know it's gonna be fun
times um super exciting i'm always
excited for any type of change i'm even
more excited that this investment has
really paid off for itself or really
paid for itself um and it was just so
lucrative for us so when
did you just fart dude
oh why are you in your underwear
you're jacked dude
buff baby
you're a buff baby
i think you might have to do more leg
workouts because that the underwear
they're just kind of fitting a little
loose duty
okay yeah so um
moms is here too to help with the whole
transition it takes a village y'all it
takes a village to raise kids it takes a
villa okay tech is pulling around
it takes a village to raise kids it
takes a village to live life
so i'm happy to have my village with me
especially my little village monkey
okay so my coffee regimen changes a lot
when i'm on a cut
usually
i love me some either korean
like it's like either korean coffee
brand or like a chinese coffee brand but
it has to be specific to something like
this
um
so this one they call it white coffee
it's a charcoal roasted i don't really
care about that what i really care about
is this packet contains the sugar the
creamer and the coffee all in one
however
all of those add unnecessary calories
that i can't afford right now on a cut
so what i'm doing is um lucky i have
really cool friends that do really rad
[ __ ] so my friend matt
vincent has his own coffee line
so this is
um actual coffee beans
so i get to control all the ingredients
in there so i have my coffee grinder i
got this on amazon i would recommend it
it's not super expensive
i'm not a big coffee connoisseur so
if you are don't listen to me because i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about um but i get my fresh coffee and
then i go with skinny syrups these are
all zero
calorie everything so i do have
caramel cream salted caramel and caramel
pecan i think there's a theme here but i
can't put my finger on it um
so i have that and then i add for my
creamer
i add
fairlife
fat free
and it does have protein so
i get low cal
high protein coffee in the morning but
let me tell you it does not taste like
this if you guys see either this brand
or something similar to this where it's
a packet full of coffee creamer and
sugar opt for it because it is
a delight and it's not going to be super
sweet or in palagosa for my spanish
speakers out there um it's not very
decadent
so um it's just like the perfect
sweetness for someone with bland taste
buds like me
lunch time now
and i ordered from a local spot called
samurai sam's if i had to compare it to
anything back in california or i mean
any other local chain um or just chain
uh it would be like a wabba grill or a
flame broiler so it's like teriyaki
chicken bowls beef
that style i think like yoshinoya but
not as bad because wobble girl flame
brother are still really really good but
samurai is sam shits
shits all over them like he eats it up
shits it out and then goes that's what
it's like samurai sam's is so damn bomb
look at this
you could
taste the char-broil look at that
the veggies are fresh everything is so
good
their teriyaki sauce is really bomb and
like not too sweet but not too blunt
it's just perfection but i just spent
like the past like 10 15 minutes
figuring out the macros because um most
of these change chains
have their nutrition facts online so
that's why i
opt for them when i don't have meal prep
or i don't make food at home
um so when i checked samurai stems or i
was going to order for them i'm like oh
it should be fine because they're a
chain out here at least so they should
have their nutrition facts um so i
ordered chicken
with cauliflower rice instead of white
rice and then veggies
i looked at the nutrition fact sheet and
they only had it
with rice so i did a bunch of math i
don't even know if this is correct so if
you see this let me show you and it's
incorrect please correct me on it i'm
pretty sure bar is going to correct me
on it but he's currently in a meeting
but check out my math okay so ready to
see my chicken scratch
so when i looked at the nutrition facts
samurai sam's dark chicken that's the
weight in grams
the calories
um and this is for the bowl okay a large
bowl so that includes the sauce the
veggies the rice
and obviously the chicken
um you got your fats carbs and proteins
then they do show you
the nutrition facts of certain items so
i did get the one for white rice
i noticed that it's 340 grams i'm not
too sure if that's the grams in the bowl
but i just assumed i got the calories
the fat
the um
carbs and then the protein so then
on the side i believe i did it down here
i didn't actually so what i did is i
took these two i subtracted oh my god it
sounds so lame like i need the butterfly
in the sky with all like the [ __ ]
equations around my brain okay so what i
did was i went this and i subtracted
this
right because i'm taking out the white
rice then this subtracted that they
subtracted that this is okay and then my
answer i added in the cauliflower so i
kept the grams the same
i'm assuming it's gonna weigh the same i
did some research online i couldn't find
anything so i'm just gonna keep
the weight the same
so with this answer
i added in the cauliflower calories and
then that's when i got
well the weight didn't change right
because it's still 638 but that's when i
got 475 calories then 14 grams i mean
you can
see what else i did but
[Music]
i feel kind of smart
like i have no idea if that's like the
correct way to go about it but like
i feel [ __ ] smart
like hello should i be teaching at a
college right now like that's how i feel
like i feel like i need to be a [ __ ]
professor in a classroom and i should be
teaching this [ __ ]
i feel [ __ ]
good
in other news
i'm about to tackle
this first room it's officially
beginning you guys it's officially
starting the packing
will commence
holy moly how long is it going to take
me
how long will this room take me okay
right now it's about 1 30. i think this
room will take me about two hours
i think it'll take me about two hours
i'll report back
check out how talented you guys are
one of you guys sent this to me clearly
i was like 20 pounds fatter
but look at how beautiful this is such
an awesome little moment
and
oh yeah look at this when mark bell sent
me this look at how jacked we look the
complete opposite of that one
look at this and look at taika what does
he got on the bar 45 135 damn dude look
at bart
wow
okay and then here
who is that young lady
her bachelor's of science
yup
i've never once hung it up and i think i
just found it a year ago
what's going on with the skeleton what's
happening why are its legs up like that
is it a guy are you a gynecologist
[Music]
now where are you
going okay
um
i don't know how to tell you this but i
think he's not gonna make it dude
he might wake up
one thing about packing that's always
cool is i always find stuff and i'm like
oh yeah what happened to that thing but
because we lived here for such a short
time and we were getting the house um
interior designed professionally i
didn't put anything up on the walls
because the walls were going to be
covered with wallpaper and different
colors
so i have a lot of these frames that i
never put up but look at how cuny this
one is
this is a story
of bart
andrea look at this guy he still had
braces in this picture
this is us in taiwan
us in paris
this is us when we finally revealed to
the world that we were together
this is us
in hawaii
when we got married
this was our europe honeymoon
when we bought our first house
when we took taika to the grand canyon
when we bought our second house oh my
god
oh lord
everybody
i would like to introduce you to
butterclone baby
no your name is bart baby you told me my
baby
bar kwon is my husband what's your name
you have to go pee pee what's going on
bye baby
hey bart baby okay
what are you doing
oh oh no your mustache dude your
mustache come back here
hey
let me see look at me hey
i think you're taika
you're a bad guy
[Applause]
okay so it's been about
one two hours i think i said maybe two
hours i remember what i said but
almost done
look at that
we're getting there we're getting there
i didn't realize it was going to take
this long obviously
but most of this stuff is already in
boxes so i'm not too worried the thing
that takes the longest is figuring out
what i want to keep and what i want to
throw away but because we've been moving
for so
many years literally back to back to
back to back to back to back to back um
there's not too many rooms like this i
would say this is
the room that i had to sort the most
after this room i don't think there's
anything else like this in the house
everything's pretty bare we don't own
very many things
that's why this house
was so goddamn big it didn't make any
sense anymore we were like
i think we have to buy a bunch of [ __ ]
in order for this house to feel less
empty
and that didn't make sense anymore
okay
monkey i want to show you something
so i found this box with papa stuff in
it
i wanted to show you something okay
ready
so i'm gonna show i'm gonna show the
camera first
so this is a picture of papa
look
that's papa's a baby
he's a cat he's a kid
yeah he's like dick
yeah
he's like a kid he's watching that
himself
he's all by himself
he's
right
by himself
is he super cute or what he he's super
cute i will rip it no don't rip it they
have to see this look at it
okay ready here's another one of papa
hold on hold on i see it
look
oh
what do you think about him
oh my god he has so much hair
he looks like a monkey
but i'm different you're different yes
it looks like a different face okay okay
let me show you another one of papa okay
ready
okay this is another one of papa
okay look
whoa whoa whoa he's not an escape
what is that a juice maybe
that's a lot of kits yeah
another one
let's see oh yeah oh my god i don't even
know what was happening here this one
looks funny look
wait don't cover your face
what face is papa making do it in the
camera
no look at the camera okay ready go go
do it
but my best friend show grandma look
grandma oh my gosh there's a corn right
here is that butterfly yep and this is a
belt right here
yeah another one yeah let's go
okay let's go go show papa that is so
funny it is so funny let's go show him
and then show him that face
[Applause]
wait for me
thank you
why did that be so funny
[Music]
see pop are you busy
knock knock
bye baby
okay we messed up papa was actually busy
and on an important phone call
yeah i have a puppy is so funny
with your
all three of you make that face and look
at me
hey bikini he thought it was so funny
hey cutie guy
he kind of looked like that guy huh no
but
you're different i'm different yeah
they have the same energy
that go into this
[Music]
my this guy is way way cooler though
this guy's later yeah he has way more
swag look at that look at that hat
i have an update can you hear the echo
[Applause]
look at this
[ __ ]
beautiful sight it took a minute because
i had to sort through things that i
wanted things that i didn't want there's
a bunch of little knickknacks and we
know that so much time is wasted
in figuring out what knickknacks you
want to keep and which do you want to
don't which ones you want to don't
yes my dude
open it is it going to jump out and bite
me no ok
hey
okay well and i moved everything
over here
nice and neat so this stuff i'm gonna
have them packaged
and put away
because they have like the
uh like the big frame and paint boxes
oh no
no no i love that that's a game that's a
toy you wanted to buy you know that i
love that you love that spider so much
i love how weird that is my love thank
you
you're so cool
[Applause]
yeah so have all this here
oh
okay go scare him
go scare him
you have a yeah yeah okay
oh you have to be scared
whoa
scary
well
well were you scared yeah i was very
scared it was a big spider i didn't see
where it came from
i didn't see where it came from monkey
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
what is happening right now that's your
son
open the door no it's so scary monkey
what's happening outside
it's raining
what
but it's
80 degree 81 degrees outside what in the
world is happening right now
nevada
you need to get your life together what
is happening can you touch it
no why
go ahead then
i'll go i had no good reason oh i think
that's dirty oh okay are you done
oh okay
well that was fast that was
wait wait
my sandbox is turning into mud
your sandbox you mean the backyard yeah
the backyard dude but you're calling it
your snapbox
he calls his the backyard his sandbox
do you like that
oh okay okay
yeah get the monkey get the monkey
how dare they send this [ __ ] to me right
now
how dare they
what is that
i don't know oh my god look at the other
side
oh
[ __ ]
okay if i could eat it right now i would
want that one just because it's so nutty
i want that
oh my god what's that
holy crap
oh my god there are coupons in here okay
wait a minute wait a minute
what is this
look at that one
holy [ __ ]
that's not that good
what the [ __ ] is in that one
damn
mall
i don't even care about ice cream to be
honest with you what the
what is that
jesus what the [ __ ] is that
oh my god what is this place
what is this place called summertime
sips and scoops
[Applause]
i wonder if it's warm what the [ __ ] is
that
what are the names of these what if i
want to order now i can't order this so
i just have to go this
that one looks okay but goddard
baby come here
look at this
m m's and a pretzel
oh look at that one peanut butter
wait where'd you see that second page
where does it say peanut butter oreo
peanut butter made with oreo
oh god
damn this is like dairy queen on
steroids i feel like you're looking at
porn like
that's what it looks like
okay that's weird no no no no no no
that's so weird
looks bomb huh
yeah well
at least today i got to eat some dessert
normally
um
my my macros are so tight
this phase in my getting lean process
that i don't really get to get um
any uh dessert at the end of it but
today
i actually messed up i was supposed to
get a different dessert but it doesn't
matter i still got the dessert so i'm
very very grateful for that
i had
oh baby
oh baby
no wait that's not it that's tyka's i oh
where the heck is it
i had this
i had that
that was so good
it had 12 grams of protein i mean the
macros aren't the best but just when i
need protein
because i always need protein and i need
to close out some carbs
and fats this one does the trick but
so it's
where you at okay so it's 12 grams of
protein
21 grams of carbs and 6
grams of fats look at that
so this isn't my ideal go-to initially
i wanted this one because this one's
only 90
and the macros on this are six
protein 14 carb 2.5 fat
this is the one i wanted but because um
i had traveled back from california from
my mom's house i stuffed i like i mixed
the box up so i scan the box because
that's what you do when you use my
finished spell
it put in this information
i thought i grabbed this but i actually
grabbed this
and then as i was eating it and enjoying
my life i was like wait 12 grams of
protein that doesn't make sense this one
isn't 12 grams of protein because i kept
thinking i was eating this
i was like no i grabbed the wrong one
and the reason why it made me sad
is because
have you ever had
honey roasted
peanuts before
yes i know you've had
but
have you ever had
honey roasted
almonds before
i know i didn't have it either
i had never tried it in honesty i always
thought i loved honey roasted only so i
went to the supermarket i saw it and
like i just grabbed it i'm like hell
yeah there's honey roasted [ __ ] i'm
gonna roast it
i come home
i scan it and i'm like whoa whoa whoa
what is this
and on accident i grabbed
honey roasted
almonds
but boy when i tell you it was the
happiest accident of my life
it was the happiest accident of my life
i'm never
going back
to honey roasted peanuts ever again ever
ever again
so bomb
um and the reason why i eat these is
when i need to fill up my fats because
my carbs are the first things i fill up
right away
then i always
what are you doing
this is for grandma just chill out
what the [ __ ] just happened
he just told grandma's story because do
you know what i just told
uh mama hey just chill out this is for
grandma [ __ ] ass he has your attitude
for sure
my jolly attitude
well i'm tired of getting verbally
abused in this house so you know what
i'm just gonna put my ass to sleep i'm
out of this [ __ ]
you can't say that
you can't say that
okay on that note
good night
he just stole
papa's water